all i need is
[Music]
with my friends
[Music]
i'm gonna keep on trying
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
oh no i did spill water right away
though so apparently fixing my lung
cavity the heart issue did not fix my
mental retardation no no you're still
about at all sorry mental handicap sorry
spanish yeah my special needs
as it comes to and thank thanks by the
way little our little mexican assistant
luna for giving me the glass with a chip
on it so now oh nice there you go cut
your lip i have a canker sore for a week
uh glad to be back i'm really glad to be
back with you guys um it's been been a
while uh it's been uh quite a by the way
that wonder years uh intro
let me just give you a quick first off
gerald a is here joel morgan how are you
sir i'm well you're doing good i'm doing
all right and we'll breathe better we'll
see just so you guys know i may have to
switch spots at some point with dave
because the breathing is still a little
bit restricted uh we'll see what happens
okay yeah all right mayo said 12 weeks
so don't do it in four yeah don't push
you split it at an even eight
i don't think this is a negotiation i
issue the medical establishment's advice
you tell the doctor how it goes yes
oh we're understaffed
shut up you silly silly [ __ ] uh
quarter black is here yo what's up
what's going on don't like that too bad
that's the least black university and uh
dave landau is here by the way dave uh
you have shows coming up in uh homestead
pennsylvania at carnegie music and the
tickets go on sale uh september 10th
right yes uh hoy and then yes uh stifle
theater in kansas and then this weekend
in uh spokane ah spokane spokane right i
don't like that they say it that way it
should be spokane like houston and then
when you're in new york like it's down
on houston street oh i get it you're one
of those affected bricks i guess it's
supposed to be houston though right
house i guess it should be but no but
there's an e at the end of house by the
way there is a promo code right now just
so you guys know crowder come back you
get 20 off a year subscription to mug
club uh and of course you get today we
will have segments that we absolutely
cannot talk about on youtube not at all
uh every day you get an hour of
additional show in the entire blaze
catalog though we will be talking listen
youtube has made it people have been
wondering if we come back obviously
because because of the legal issues with
youtube
um
what this show will look like and if
we'll be pulling back or putting our
foot on the gas and there are things
you're not allowed let me be really
clear there are things you're not
allowed to talk about on your right
we've always said it's their sandbox we
have to play by their rules
uh for example they don't they
don't want you talking about ivermectin
which we'll do today very thoroughly
which we are doing today and they yeah
it's kind of just like laying it out so
we'll be talking about that the
differences between donald trump's
withdrawal uh plans with afghanistan
versus joe biden because that's a common
thing now everyone's been saying
actually he just inherited this problem
oh right yeah like like obama did with
bush for eight years well like daddy
like son biden yes he inherited peace
yeah and a plan was already in place all
you have to do is follow it who'd have
thought that you could just replace john
lennon's lyrics with trump oh who knew
stephen no he's a dictator
and a new trump just begun that's what i
would do and so this is trump trump it
could be lazy there you go yeah
my question to you is uh what did you
think about the afghanistan withdrawal
and how do you think that it differs
and then what have your thoughts been on
uh
on the ivorm you know that they've
labeled it horse paced yeah to me any
any reporter who refers to ivermectin's
horse pace is guilty of journalistic
malpractice not offering medical advice
correct yeah however it is a
prescription available and prescribed to
humans in the billions i think it's 250
million human beings every year we'll
get to that any journalist who says
horse-paced horse dewormer is guilty of
malpractice little aside we did the
wonder years intro and uh
there was a rumor i guess dave gerald
and i remembered yes yeah the kid from
the wonder years
had become marilyn manson correct now
it's not true not yeah absolutely
however whoever came up with that
conspiracy
did a ton of due diligence because he
looks like he could absolutely be
marilyn manson i would have ran with it
yes exactly if i was marilyn manson ever
said yeah i was the kid yeah yeah
fred savage is not what he appears on tv
he's a monster right
that's why his name's savage
so i was talking with all of the people
who were some of the millennials and i
never heard of that i said you never
heard that it was the rumor that he was
from there's also the rumor of the ribs
but that he was a kid from that's about
one year he said no and then dave walks
in 15 minutes later because he was late
and he goes uh all right you're gonna
dress me up as uh mayor the marilyn
manson kid yeah so totally unprompted no
i completely remember the rumor that was
the deal he was marilyn manson i still
believe it it's like santa yes now uh
before we move on uh to everything else
we have a lot of news to get to some
stuff that happened on cnn this morning
yep uh look
people are stranded in afghanistan still
that's still going on and the media has
moved on now to just try and blame
anyone who's unvaccinated he said it's a
success it's a success
100 percent every american who wants to
talk and it's like 90 of most americans
get out yeah like we think that a lot of
americans are here now
that's a fun thing but we're not a
voucher oh really thanks chauncey that's
a fun way of saying ten percent didn't
make it yeah yeah because we left yeah
that's that's a thing thousands of
people are going to be burned or hanged
from helicopters sorry um but a lot
happened between the break and i'll talk
about that more in mud club because you
guys don't all want to know what i went
through but uh
twins a lot of fun yeah yeah
congrats man
did you just start a phrase like yeah i
was gonna say happy something and then i
i was like what does that do happy two
babies
happy twins i hope they are for you oh
i'm a twin i've i i think they're going
to be uh a handful yeah they are a
handful we're very fortunate actually
and i will say this my wife is an
unbelievable mother just
you just realize right away the
difference between men and women yeah
she's just i talked about this i think
in one of the documentaries but right
away she's just you know feeding doing
this pumping on and just turning it over
okay bourbon and then going back and i'm
just like
is the head supported it's like am i
supporting the head the babies
and you're leaving to go get cigarettes
yes
i think they make them malleable just
for the fathers like they can bend and
break a little bit and they won't well
i'm not allowed to lift anything over
eight pounds and the babies were twins
born two weeks early at seven pounds ooh
that's close so um i thought what was it
perfect so you use them like shake
weights yeah
a little exercise that's not that works
no they're not the sharpest twins around
but you know what the luck of the
genetic draw don't worry they'll roll
off the changing table at one point that
happens to all fathers and you won't
tell her about it then when you do just
go
but when you do she'll go oh yeah that
happens
you're like what do you mean that
happens like a lot like wait wow that
happens all the time
sometimes i just i don't think there's
yeah why do you think there's a pad
right next to the chain all right so a
lot happened while we were gone
this was two months while i was gone
anyway thank you guys for holding on the
fort and uh
how could we fit it all in and i gotta
tell you know from my hospital bed from
the icu bed i was sitting at the tv
going now to the point where one of the
nurses came in and said we should
probably shut off cnn yeah it's a good
call
morphine drift yeah and i get some more
dilaudid because chris cuomo is about to
come on and i feel i feel like there's
gonna be a chris cuomo shaped hole in
that television set
by the way can't you get a can't you get
an lcd you guys are still using old
projection screens get an lcd like okay
let's just turn this to animal planet
yeah attenborough he's a dick too so
a lot happened and i was just screaming
at the screen wanting to to get in there
uh wasn't able to and so how do we cover
the two months that have taken place
since i've uh been gone this is not
something uh that has never been done
before this is not something that has
never been done before on this show uh
lest you be unappreciative however it is
still the most effective way so we
decided to put the last two months of
news into a song for your convenience
[Music]
falls from your brother chris fake news
playing to sanchez whitmer and the fbi
oh yeah i almost died
[Music]
[Applause]
ben and jerry hate hasids twitter says
horns for kids tucker spied by nsa
hockey player says i'm gay obama is a
super
spreader [ __ ] afghanistan
not a guy lost control afghanistan the
taliban is back
left our allies in disgrace isis t-bags
biden's face military weapon stock
upgrade from a rock pelosi is still a
hag at least matt damon won't say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
unoriginal but it works hey it's a
catchy tune yeah oh it's horrifying
i love how they found the one clip of
matt damon actually saying yeah this is
my thing with matt damon when i was
reading this and i was in
i think i was in the icu at this point
when i don't remember what happened i
was either the mayor and by let me one
thing let me just say to everybody out
there uh just i have this platform i
would like to help people genuinely if
you have anything
wrong with you
that you need to go to mayo clinic don't
think about it go to mayo clinic there
are levels to this thing and it's a
whole different yeah stratosphere of
care it is unbelievable they all
communicate
any of the complications are entirely my
own doing i was stupid this actually
happened i they said oh well you'll be
up and you'll be able to walk the next
day just don't lift anything like above
eight pounds for like eight twelve weeks
yeah i said i'll be able to walk go and
then i left five days early on a plane
which they did not want me to do right
like stay and i was like i can't stay i
got stuff to do
so
i get on a plane then i call them i said
well how's the progress going i said
well you know i feel i feel pretty
winded though like i so i went i did a
grocery run and then i was at costco but
i got winded i had to sit on the like
the liquor cart and i said you went are
you out of your [ __ ] mind what do you
think
so you said i could be walking you see
we meant from like your bedroom to the
kitchen
no you're going to doing a grocery run
so was my fault it was you but mayo
unbelievable um
what was it oh matt damon yeah and i was
watching this story unfold i remember
sitting there he said you know i told a
joke to my daughter i used the f word
and she she said you know oh that's a
that's a an old word dad or that's a
word we don't use anymore and i thought
well it's just a joke and i was sitting
there going matt damon these people are
in such a bubble they have such a lack
of self awareness
did you think they were going to give
you grace
do you think they weren't going to come
and try and crucify you because you were
telling the story about how you were no
longer going to use it it doesn't matter
you used it once paula dean said the n
word once the answer in deposition he
said have you ever said the n word right
and everyone else in the country who's
ever glanced at paula deen could have
answered that question for you yes she
said yes
guilty done matt damon thought they
would be okay with it no what rock is he
hiding under where now is the time that
he's finding out that that word was like
15 years ago people were like yeah we
probably shouldn't say that oj got
acquitted because of that
it was just like have you ever said it
mark furman and he's like i've never
even heard of it yeah you just say no
and then they're like well we have you
on tape saying it 11 times ordering a
pizza
that's not me no he's like i don't know
this is definitely vermin this is how i
order pizza bring it to my house you
gotta take it up with jets nazi frags
former vice president
it's appropriate if you're if you're if
you're lobbing it at nazis it's just
crazy though because matt damon's the
one that leaked it in an interview yeah
yeah why did you why did you bring it up
yeah who's his pr you know what he
thought he was going to gain points like
look guys i don't say this anymore like
uh hold on a second you must be
forgiveness grace you must be thinking
of those right-wing christians you said
it ever
he's like listen i was just telling my
young daughter gay bashing jokes like we
do at the dinner table and she corrected
me i say gay bashing joke you say
rollerblading accident the point is will
had a little bit of fun it was good he
was desperate for attention he needed to
be in the media his last few movies have
not been good no well they've been
really bad but i do like him they still
try to make him out to be a tough guy
all five foot two inches of them okay so
before we move on to people who are
still stranded in the united states
which is a serious story that the media
is not giving it attention oh america
people from the united states stranded
in afghanistan right
now to manchester united's still
stranded here too i mean it just depends
on where you look it's a problem with
our allies being stranded there because
you know biden handed over um
his rolodex their
private phone numbers uh thumb prints
and a list of their hobbies gps
coordinates an interpreter that helped
him yeah yeah he also
set up a fake dating game show to just
like just just so that yeah people could
show up and be like oh okay we're gonna
arrest you it's not a dating game if
they invite you to play a game there is
no family feud in afghanistan it's just
a trip doesn't exist well there is but
it's just hitting your wife with rocks
it's just steve harvey showing up like
now this man come from the taliban
and
he likes shut a mantra
any time a white person says anything on
that steve harvey treats them like
garbage what do you take you're so
stupid yeah what do you think to a
picnic uh sandwiches sandwiches
sandwiches
oh i see sandwiches you all waiting on
winnie the pooh it is honey you wanting
to bring some honey you want some honey
crack ass crackers
the legend legend oh all right
but before we move on to that we did
want to react really quickly uh we're
going to be talking about covid the
numbers too and you blame the
unvaccinated i blame the fat so let's
lead this off with uh lefties on tick
tock have taken to spoken word poetry
commonly referred to as people who
weren't good enough for the open mic cut
to express their um
uh
astronomical
progressive achievements
this year
we fought the bad men who pulled our
skirts
[Music]
whose voices riddled protest signs and
prayer marches
the women who worked wouldn't hold
higher office as the girl who'd been
raped had asked for it again she who
knew nothing of pain until her gender
betrayed her he knowing nothing of us
but our will to be small we were not
easy made into silence we're using our
voices and being unstill we with our
hands out and chest cracked from
climbing are taking the awkwardness i
hate spoken word poetry soft boiled eggs
and a crack
our time ever blooming your chest isn't
cracking from anything but gravity they
who have choked us with bleak
perseverance on their old grounding is
where we shall stand we the believers
who have never forgotten that life
liberty of a red white and blue we who
unbounded and unresurrected stood up to
the bad men and shouted me too the bad
man this year we aren't quiet
amending our textbooks unwriting our
ghost lines and strict gender roles no
matter our gender our ghosts showed up
to rattle your cabinets
and marched to the poles
the women voted the ghosts calls it a
haunted house
you know how ghosts flick the light
switch on and off her ghost just turns
them off
i just can't the lights keep going my
creator please decide up or down
she's doing such lamb poetry
the ghost in her house just flips off
the lights and goes move
imagine that tattoo artist yes oh you
gotta move that over you need a whole
mechanism you would have it would have
to be continual requests for consent
yeah just just in the just when we're
talking about the mechanics of it you
have to you have to move it over it's
like a mad folding i was sad
yes i'm glad she obviously wanted us to
focus on her words like that that was
the most pressing thing that she yeah
focus on my words and not my tit tattoo
or the fact that i just think she had
such great poetry why did she live in
such an awful home
oh that's true it must just be well the
artist thing home is where you make it
that is true
home is where your eight cats are
fridge full of
glenstone ribs
[Laughter]
oh my goodness you want an astral they
were like we have flintstone vitamins
yeah but do you have flintstone rack of
lamb yes do you have car tipping ribs
i need a snack okay
um
this is something so the taliban we're
going to get into the difference between
withdrawal plans and my question to you
is
how many americans do you think have
been left behind if you had to estimate
and we'll get into some kind of general
so by the way best thing you can do too
on youtube just comment just comment
below that helps with the algorithm uh
if you want to smash the like button
that's great
so the taliban just so you know glenn
beck who actually does work at the blaze
if you join mug club you get access to
his show yeah and regardless of where
you line up with his politics or
previous stances the guy has been doing
a lot of good work yes and going over
there and a lot of americans have been
doing tremendous work um trying to get
americans out yeah they raised a ton of
money of afghanistan you're talking
about you're talking about i don't know
if it's hundreds of millions
collectively when you add up all the
organizations but it's certainly in the
high tens of millions yeah glenn beck
actually uh he's been working with the
charity mission one
and allegedly we don't have all the
information here the taliban is holding
six planes hostage
wow one yeah six points
of us passengers yeah okay u.s
passengers uh this is a quote from an
article an ngo told newsweek the planes
are currently empty and its passengers
are still waiting in their safe house
for clearance for takeoff from the
taliban i have more than 1 000 people on
the master manifest that want to fly of
which 123 are americans and the rest are
special immigrant visas now here's the
thing
remember they said all of it what
matters is the claim that they
made joe biden said there would be no
complications of withdrawal and he said
well you couldn't do this without any
kind of complications he said no
americans who
will be left behind then it was most
americans have been uh you know they've
been uh taken back home and the ones and
then i told i remember telling gerald uh
off air said watch the narrative is
going to be well the ones who are there
wanted to stay there or they were told
for months how to move well look if they
tell you for months how you can leave
the country and say hey we're going to
uh you know extract our
our troops you should leave the country
but you show up and you're locked out of
the airport yeah it's not helpful the
fact is there are thousands of americans
and allies right now on at least dozens
of planes the reporting obviously is
very secretive so we don't know exactly
the number and i couldn't give it to you
if i had it who want to leave the
country who have been trying to leave
for a very long time and who cannot and
i want to go to thought after but this
was going on this morning
with cnn's brianna brianna kaler brianna
keller um not poppy harlow the other
blonde and there was a man on there who
was talking working for another
organization talking about trying to get
americans out and being stonewalled by
the state department i guarantee you and
you can go and search this and watch the
whole segment at scene and i encourage
you to they did not expect this man to
discuss this because watch when brianna
goes from cnn's brianna goes from uh
being allegedly a journalist to
absolutely carrying the water for the
state department and administration this
is not the kind of questioning this is
not the kind of interview that a
journalist conducts if they're
interested in learning the truth here we
go this was this morning first i want to
ask you about this particular
characterization of what happened by the
u.s state department because you said
you didn't necessarily want to be
talking about this in the press but here
you are and you're taking issue you're
taking very much issue with how the
state department is characterizing this
so i just want to get to the bottom of
what you're taking issue with because
the state department said the us has
facilitated the safe departure of four
u.s citizens by overland route from
afghanistan embassy staff was present
upon arrival so uh just to be clear are
you saying that they actually did not
facilitate the overland departure of
these four are you saying that embassy
staff were not present at the exit
they they got present on the second day
uh we we traveled over 300 miles with
miriam uh not we personally not me i was
actually in the united states over 300
miles from the bull
up through this is after he said
out of it because we hopefully will get
more people through but we had her there
for 24 hours before the state department
was even aware she was there they didn't
show up until a few hours after we'd
actually or before we got her across our
guys with the sentinel foundation
literally walked across the bridge and
was trying to negotiate with the taliban
not the state department our guys the
sentinel foundation who is non-political
whatsoever they don't only want to be in
the picture bless them they wanted they
they do this all over the country
or all over the world they were taken on
the negotiations but when i seen the
state department come out and take
credit she's about to interrupt you
absolutely
so it sounds like what you're saying is
they didn't it was the group you're
involved with that shepherd shepherded
uh this woman and her three kids through
the overland route the state department
obviously did come in at the end and
they helped get this person
goody for the state department not
government property they came in at the
end once they use wire once they use
bolt cutters to get a cut cut a little
uh representative shaped hole through
the fence yeah so you want credit for
people to ha having to walk 300 miles
through taliban-infested hell and if
they finally make their way to you might
be able to get them out that's your
credit could you imagine just anyone at
cnn asking that kind of a question and
carrying trump's water oh no no way
never one american left behind right
would have been the end of trump's
administration in their eyes
that's unbelievable i can't believe that
american citizens are having to go over
there right now and this is not the only
group doing that no no there have been
hundreds of people that have gone over
and taking care of people that we have
made promises to not just joe biden
saying all americans are going to get
out this is going to be no big deal the
people who put their lives and families
on the line to work with us that we said
we will take care of you that we left
there are many many many thousands more
of those still waiting to get out oh i
don't think so biden said that none of
those people want to fight oh that no
they don't want to leave dave they
they're actually who would want to leave
a country where people are getting beat
yeah well they're actually cool with the
taliban coming over they prepared a nice
dinner for them countries no quiznos i
know right i don't know how they do it
you don't have to think about it dude i
mean my toasty goodness that's right
we're going to move on to a whole
segment on the difference between donald
trump and biden in afghanistan because
that was a talking point too he says
well you inherited trump's mess well
trump wanted to withdraw very very
different i don't think anyone here is
against the idea that we need to
withdraw from no not at all no there's a
right way to do it and there's a wrong
way to do it and i'll get into that in a
second but first uh this is you know the
texas abortion law yeah by the way if
here here's what you do if you're around
people who are who are uh anti-abortion
you refer to the texas abortion laws as
common sense sensible abortion laws
i just watched their heads explode
it's common sense
so
i don't know
uh bette miller by the way is she won't
until the abortion laws rescinded she
won't put out thank god oh dang it you
mean i can't
i can't give me a piece of middler
she's walking around like somebody
somebody wants no no
it's funny how i've advocated abstinence
so that you can avoid unwanted
pregnancies and they're advocating
abstinence so that they can have more
unwanted pregnancies yeah well she's
also admitting that men want sex more
and women use it as a weapon yeah while
failing to realize that the rule doesn't
apply to bette midler no ever there are
zero men put out by that they're like ah
bed mitler's off the table nobody is she
even married is she with anybody i don't
know i have no idea oh we could
the satanic temple
has now though found a roundabout way
against the texas law uh the official
twitter for the satanic temple by the
way donald trump's still banned oh okay
taliban still up on the uh okay on the
other side still up on the twitter
satanic temple still up on the twitter
though i think the satanic temple should
be allowed to be upon yeah because it's
hilarious uh they announced a lawsuit
over the texas abortion law well one
satanist does
the satanic temple says they have a
strategy for women to access the
abortion drug take it as part of a
religious expression its founder
describes them as a non-theistic
religious group by non-theistic we mean
we don't worship a literal
deity we looks exactly like whatever
metaphorical construct is the ultimate
rebel against tyranny oh no i never
thought that the uh head of the satanic
temple would have the inglorious
bastards haircut and a marble eye
ever just kind of askew a little bit
be holding it so the temple tweeted its
opposition to this new law saying
abortion laws in texas violate our
religious rights and take legal action
if texas judges abide by the
constitutional and legal precedent then
those who share our deeply held beliefs
will be exempt from the state's
inappropriate efforts to restrict access
to
abortion services what's going on
what the oh that's uh that's dr devil
walrus uh the local abortionist here
since the texas law passed he's been
moonlighting here as a janitor
on saturdays
oh he keeps just showing up
it's saturday come on devil walrus sorry
i know you love vacuums but it doesn't
mean you should just come by any time um
devil was an opening well i'm glad he
wore a mask he's very rude yeah yeah
he's just not a nice guy he's actually
part of that satanic church is he really
yeah he's kind of their mascot
as opposed to the guy with the marble
eye yeah well they're both uh equally
respectable in my eyes here's the thing
you know that you know because these
guys are pansies the uh the satanic
temple people and they don't they're not
actually like they don't worship real
satan they're just just practiced
atheists right right of course yeah they
weren't
i do want to know the story behind that
i it's like either okay a it was an
accident that had
completely outside of his own free will
that happened and he needed to get a
fake eye in which case he's just like
i'll roll with it become a satanist or
then i want to know if he was a satanist
and said i want to freak people out with
this i if he a uses a contact lens or b
actually committed spooned out his eye
and put in a glass eye in the name of
satan because that's the only way i
would respect anyone in the satanic
temple if he spooned out his eye and put
in
a marvel or glass eye or commitment or
he blamed god because he's a
butterfinger with lawn darts oh well see
a lot of people are you know you're on
the right side when the uh the satanists
come to your defense right you're like
well who's on our side well you got the
satanists over there they think this is
a good idea yeah you know the devil hold
on anybody who's worshippers uh well we
have this uh this titty tattooed
tick-tock
no i'm pretty happy to watch that there
no i don't think she has to worry about
pregnancy lasting more than eight
minutes
where is she behind those spencer plasma
balls no no the desk is a little high
could you move those out of the way
well uh sammy davis jr was a satanist
briefly that's true yeah that's true
towards the end of his world yeah but
he's ah
yeah
the satan man can
he also had a glass side maybe that's
overtake a sacrifice
yeah maybe he's doing it to be like
sammy he's like everybody's got to have
one glass eye to be a worshiper uh by
the way also speaking of boycotts over
the weekend portland mayor ted wheeler
uh-huh he's back
yeah he announced that the city uh is
going to try and boycott travel goods
and services from texas
and you know what here's the thing i
can't believe this this is uh you know
this seems like it might actually be a
violation of state law federal law um i
support it
yeah
i'm very honored we entirely support the
boycott here at lottery's car we have
some suggestions for other goods and
services okay that we don't want from
portland uh for example uh let's start
with homeless tent dealerships yeah oh
yeah smelly smelly drum circles that's a
good one those are yeah yeah those are
uh
car fire started by someone whose life
matters yeah there you go you don't need
that maybe uh cammy the hiv positive
orphan muppet from sesame street who
probably lives in portland yeah probably
does live in japan yeah
guess where she's from it's gotta be
poor that's a real muslim no africa what
yep for real that's a real sesame street
character sorry what yeah the aids
riddled uh puppet that's real that hold
on leave that up that's real that is a
trail wait that's an african puppet uh
well she comes from africa i think it's
come from the apartheid state
clearly i've seen black puppets that is
not one of them yeah i think it's where
the white actors come from they claim
they're african-american she's from the
same place she's voiced by charlize
theron yes
you clearly have black puppets available
and you chose not to use it they're like
how can we it's from africa what should
we do well i probably should give it
aids yeah oh well yeah it is sesame
street
you seen blood diamond no i will watch
it in the green room yeah her and
snuffleupagus have been sharing needles
we uh we have confirmation that bette
miller is married and this is our house
she's married oh
he looks like a falcon unless you count
the maid and any other woman he can in
his hands
he hasn't been getting any fro
oh it's a devil walrus why do you think
you were busy on saturdays
i want to see that with a feather duster
uh
by the way i just think that texas
shouldn't do business with any cities
that are controlled by terrorist
organizations so portland there you go
you do you we're fine who knew this was
how we would stem the tide just pass
laws that liberals hate they'll stop
coming here and they'll leave we should
keep that that's great should absolutely
keep doing it there's another quick
story of fake news we have so much
there's so much it's like drinking a lot
of fire hose uh and uh i appreciate you
guys spending what are they talking
about here on cnn island but double
murder investigate uh who cares okay
okay i thought that they were going into
murder not covering the americans
stranded in afghanistan oh they are not
covering it why did they stop covering
that oh you're like well
looks like our work here is done mission
accomplishment he said 90
that's more than the peaceful protest of
last year that's gotta be good that's a
good number mostly peaceful escape yes
mostly successful evacuation
you to know how bad it's going to be
picture the taliban before now add
countless american armaments yeah yeah
well more than they already had and the
pallets of cash yes that was given to
them by what administration yeah pallets
of cash
uh blackhawks anyway right here's
another fake news story and i know some
of you know about this but uh some of
you may not have heard of this and this
is
going to be important because we're
going to go back to ivermecton and talk
about that again not offering any
medical advice but there's a lot of
people don't know anything about it
uh so we'll talk about that but first
here's a story that many people know
this was their introduction to
ivermectin over the weekend it was
reported and this was all over the place
rachel maddow rolling stone that a
hospital in oklahoma
had no beds because of too many people
and they were saying so many poison
control
situations calls by the way someone can
call poison control is this poisonous
and they say no okay that's a poison
control call but these haven't really
actually been proven the media's just
run with a story so this guy who claimed
to be uh an emergency room doctor in an
oklahoma hospital so they had no beds
because of too many people eating
ivermectin horse paste here's the story
as it happened in real time there's a
reason you have to have a doctor to get
a prescription for this stuff because it
can be dangerous dr jason meghelier
saying patients are packing southeastern
oklahoma emergency rooms taking
ivermectin doses meant for a full-sized
horse believing false claims it could
fight coven 19.
full-sized tick-tocker that gunshot
victims were having hard times getting
to facilities where they could get
definitive care and be treated something
miguelier says is now backing up small
town ambulance systems too all of their
ambulances
are stuck at the hospital waiting for a
bed to open so that they can take the
patient in okay don't let me forget to
go back to why they're why the beds are
are so sparse right now that's something
i want to go back to but first the story
is not true now it was covered by rachel
maddow who i don't believe at the time
of this
show has issued an apology that's uh
overlay d uh warning about uh vision
laws i guess what the drug rolling stone
published the article uh it wasn't true
at all she's not a doctor not a doctor
rachel maddow's not no but her glasses
she's a [ __ ] she's a mixologist though
oh yeah
that young man makes a mean sidecar your
degree is in cocktails
i never knew that bert ward made such a
good manhattan
we've got somebody shot in the ambulance
and a doctor horse comes out and just
clicks his heel twice now
so here's how we know it's not true
because rachel maddow i'm not a doctor
writers at rolling stone as far as i
know not a doctor right also who knows
like rolling stone doctor a hospital in
oklahoma released or the hospital
released a statement refuting dr
mcclay's claim saying although dr jason
maclean is not an employee of nhs
sequoia he is affiliated with the
medical staffing group that provides
coverage for our emergency room with
that said dr mcclay has not worked at
our sallisaw location which is what he
claimed for over two months yeah nhs
sequoia has not treated any patients due
to complications related to taking
ivermectin this includes not treating
any patients for ivermectin overdose all
patients who visited our emergency room
have received medical attention as
appropriate our hospital has not had to
turn away any patients seeking emergency
care
and uh
just for fun just so you know the and i
made sure that this that i'm about to
show you these reviews are from before
this story right we found some of the
funnest reviews of dr mcclaire
from his patients hey so in other words
here's the thing the media went with
this the media went with the story
at a certain point you can't say they're
ignorant they knowingly didn't do any
due diligence they knowingly avoided
research if it didn't fit their
narrative because they want you to think
that any alternative treatment is either
dangerous someone has a financial vested
interest in it yeah or it's veterinary
medicine which is not the case for
ivermectin it is used in both humans and
animals for crying out loud my
sister-in-law has a dog on prozac it
happens all the time dog thrilled about
it
yeah the dog's got to stop eating that
out of her purse though
it feels great also a little bit of
weight gain yeah so uh here are the
reviews of dr macleod from his patients
absolutely
horrible experience with this obviously
ego maniacal borderline criminally
negligent social popular wow
tried to give an end stage liver patient
3 000 milligrams of tylenol because of
the opioid crisis had to take his orders
to a pharmacist to get a statement to
prove to the facility what had happened
bedside manner was very dismissive and
accusatory overall he was awful here's
another one
this man's liver's damage what do you
want to do prescribe him more liver
damage yes
here's another one too he's a smart
mouth and i wouldn't recommend this
[Laughter]
house slow life freak to anyone if you
go to this doctor you are nuts
he's a smart mouth oh he's a freak he's
like he's a freak he's like patch adams
but he's moody
[Laughter]
just prescribes tylenol yeah
more tylenol father scolding a child
that's like hey how about 3 000
milligrams of tylenol hey you know how
liver works their smart mouth
i don't like her that's why i prescribed
it i was hopeful if you've seen her dick
tattoo oh my gosh how much tylenol i'm
going to need to get rid of that
so
just rub some tylenol
this is the guy they went this is like a
guy who got fired from wendy's for like
you know dipping himself in the frosty
machine and then he tells everybody it's
a disgusting place to eat it's like are
you sure it's not you i think it's you
sir
your
imprints
in singular lone hair didn't you choke
somebody in line i did but i mean it's
what i'm saying wendy's just horrible no
that was when i was at waffle house oh
you failed it both by the way here's
something too you're having a wife who's
a nurse yeah they talk about hospital
beds being over on that here's here's
the truth they actually a lot of
hospitals have first off let me go
through a couple of things here
hospitals and you can correct me if i'm
wrong hospitals operate very near
capacity they hope to yeah always
because it's about a it's about profit
margins in other words if they have a
bunch of unused capacity often they'll
end up closing those down or they won't
staff them right now they actually have
more beds than the media is telling you
but they are understaffed the reason
they are understaffed is because they've
laid off a record number of nurses and
furloughed them because they had to stop
elective procedures and there weren't
enough coveted patients i know this
because i was in the icu for non-coveted
reasons and it was understaffed and hard
for me to get a bed even though there
was no covet patient in the hospital
yeah just to be clear do i have that
about right yeah and hospitals actually
do fill up and go on what they call
diversion where they send people either
to other units but that are not
necessarily going to be in that specific
you know kind of category at first maybe
go to the er and you would go somewhere
else they take you somewhere else or
they send you to another hospital this
happens because hospitals it's like
going to the restaurant and seeing five
empty tables and seeing that there's a
30-minute wait to eat it's like well you
got empty tables we don't have any
servers right you don't have any nurses
to take care of you so we can't put you
in these beds and if they have so many
open beds they're paying for them they
want capacity to be high so when you're
being told 80 to 90 percent of these
beds are taken oh my gosh it's like well
it wasn't zero last week no we had an
ambulance or we had an uh injury in our
family you know over the summer i don't
get into it but it's like yeah had to be
ambulance to another hospital
frosty well it's
listen when you try to put the thing
under the frosty sometimes i don't want
to talk about it if it's more of a
grinder well see i had a rib removed
like marilyn manson and i fell off my
bed no but you went in
i
almost broke my neck at least he sleeps
in the bottom bunk now that's true
that's true thanks so much you're much
safer oh my god no uh same thing i went
to the icu i went this is so this is
true do you guys want to hear the story
about how i i struck a nurse i do wait
oh yes i remember yeah so before this by
the way
follow us on instagram and on tick tock
if you guys aren't already even though
tick tock is destroying the country um
if you want to know the best way to
watch the show it's a live show yeah
right monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern just tune in because search
algorithm browse isn't going to work so
you can join my club just tune in monday
through thursday 10 a.m eastern uh and
we'll be taking your life like button
smash
the like button smash it so here's what
happened
i wasn't planning i didn't want to make
it home
but uh you should i had the surgery and
then i pushed it too
fast too hard and so i gained 30 pounds
in like two weeks oh wow to the point
where i was going to jerry's relatively
healthy so i cut out all sugar then i
cut out all carbs then i'm just but the
problem is then i was trying to exercise
more to try and lose some weight and the
weight kept going up and i'm going home
in a second i ate i ate uh i i ate two
eggs and i ate a piece of salmon this
doesn't make sense like michael like
tyson looking at his bank account when
done
took it down from 180 million to five
like oh what did i buy so
then it
it filled up with fluid so this is what
happened i told the story i'll do the
brief version you can go back and watch
a sort of mini documentary um it got to
the point where i was getting really
winded and had the spirometer my breath
was getting worse getting worse and
worse to the point where i couldn't get
out of bed i couldn't breathe yeah and
i've talked about this where i was kind
of going in and out of consciousness and
the muscles that you use to breathe you
sort of take for granted right if you're
working out you get that lactic acid
buildup this symbolizes working out if
you improperly use a squat rack curling
and uh or my babies shake weights
so elaine what happened
what happened is at that point i'm going
oh my gosh i can see stars and now my
diaphragm is exhausted i thought there
was a 50 feet shot that i may not yeah
wake up
go so i can't breathe
johnny boy takes me to the hot the
emergency room again there was no one
there this was maybe five something in
the morning yeah no one there we still
had to wait
so i go in and uh i'm about
able to take
one
breath like the black and welcome in the
middle in the wheelchair i'm talking and
i go in and this nurse in the emergency
room goes uh and i have a mask
underneath my and she goes mask
and i go
no
judge
show the thing because i have a card for
mayo with a picture of the bars through
my ribs and like for tsa right in case
there's breathing complications she goes
i don't care mask and she goes and she
reaches the mask under my chin and she
doesn't like aggressively almost like
smears it over my well i'm laying back
over my face above my nose and i just
instinctively went no
i went like that
exactly and it was a little bit louder
than i intended it was like a
and at that point oh no
i realized i just hit a nurse
and we're looking around you could hear
rat piss on cotton
i'm surprised you didn't hear a slow
clap like at the end of it
from everybody there and so then after
that i look and john looks and he's sort
of hands over the card with the picture
of my bars in my chest and she goes well
it doesn't matter it doesn't affect your
oxygen levels anyway and you know we did
this study where i went to the gym with
the math it does and so i didn't have
but i have time or the breath to explain
it all i said was
it's [ __ ]
don't touch me
and she said well we might not be able
to get you a bed tonight because we
might not be able to admit you because
uh where did you see you finish up with
covet patients and one there was this
wonderful nurse name named ramona who
said that's total book crop we don't
have any in this hospital yeah we have
six in the entire hospital network we
just don't have enough nurses so that
was what i went through i struck a nurse
sorry hero justified yeah hero
not all heroes wear capes all right some
wear masks i guess some wear a face slap
because they deserve this
can you imagine that being your first
thought somebody who can't breathe
that's walking in like no you have to
mask up which will restrict your oxygen
what a jerk there's little rods in his
ribs and you're like how would that
affect breathing
she was a temp okay dave i'm sorry
reception she just admitted
oh i forgot you're so special
how would no legs affect jumping
that wouldn't affect it couldn't you
just get some moon boots huh you got no
thumbs you got trouble holding stuff
doesn't make sense what's the matter
with you kid i'm a nurse
how do you use an oven mitt with no
thumbs that's weird gross
that's the first thing you think of i
like oven mitts you're the 11th person
that's hit me today
oh
i should have never taken a job as bette
midler's maid
i look just like her
i think that's the problem i think he
thinks it's her
it doesn't help that we always wear the
devil walrus mask okay
so he looks hot and hocus pocus compared
to now yeah
by the way did you know that uh hocus
pocus that film hocus pocus i think they
might be doing a sequel but you know in
that film sarah jessica parker
no prosthetics oh
oh wow
so let's go through biden versus trump
on afghanistan here uh this is something
that's been going on for a while but the
media has just moved on as though it's
normal and i again i want to hear from
you guys if you ever actually bought
this if you understood and if you were
able to articulate this is something i
think a lot of people need to be able to
do is articulate the difference between
a good withdrawal
and a disastrous withdrawal
no one here has a problem with
withdrawing from afghanistan nope no and
certainly when you look at there's a
case we made when people say second
amendment or you're going to foot off
your government with guns uh 70 000
something taliban over i think was 400
000 afghan members and they were fleeing
and there's a big part of this look if
they're not willing to fight for their
own country we shouldn't be sending
americans to die to fight for them the
people who did help us we had agreements
with of course we need to take care of
those people who put their ass on the
line but not the people fleeing
buildings telling the taliban like they
never touched it so
[Applause]
um
this is the the narrative that biden has
been setting i've never heard a
president accept less responsibility
aside from maybe barack obama uh
trying to blame it numerous times on
trump i think we have a montage yeah my
predecessor the former president
signed an agreement with the taliban
to remove u.s troops by may the first
just months after i was inaugurated
it included no requirement that taliban
work out a cooperative government
arrangement
with the afghan government
but it did authorize the release
of 5 000 prisoners last year we'll get
to including some of the taliban's top
war commanders
among those
who just took control of afghanistan
i inherited a diplomatic agreement
duly negotiated between the government
of the united states and the taliban
agreement that all u.s forces would be
out of afghanistan by may 1.
big league 22 is in your mouth right now
just three months after he's a red man
guy that's what we inherited that
commitment you are fake news perhaps not
what i would have negotiated myself
but it was an agreement made by the
united states government
and that means something not with you so
first off this is something that matters
is
okay if you want to blame donald trump
again very very different policies yeah
however
that doesn't hold water there are plenty
of donald trump's policies executive
orders initiatives that fine immediately
undid what was the mexico city policy
the keystone xl pipeline the 1776
commission in other words he came in and
with just a flick of his pen undid all
kinds of trump policies he didn't with
afghanistan until a rushed one slash two
give or take a few hours withdrawal so
right off the bat you have to expect you
have to accept some responsibility uh
sweetheart also let's stop giving them
the respect of pronouncing taliban in
their native tongue taliban taliban
taliban taliban why because go screw
yourselves that's why we're going to
mispronounce it just to aggravate you
the taliban like well hold on a second
look they're worthy of respect
i don't think they can get more pissed
at us anyway so let's do it like you're
a terrible ant ordering in an italian
restaurant right italian italian but
that's what we should do with the
taliban do you think he's getting really
just look at him i think that's who
stephen king had in mind when he was
writing pet cemetery to be judged
randall
like he just started to come out and be
like don't go across that road
it's mighty busy keep your baby keep
your son off that road now dave he
couldn't enunciate like that that's true
government
he stumbled on agreement
[Music]
i went i went to afghanistan the ground
is sour
[Laughter]
just ridiculous
i've seen
i've seen just dead fake plants that are
looking more alive than him come on man
a fake ficus that had more vibrancy
i would rather be lead but okay so let's
get down to this though what uh what it
comes down to is what did trump want to
do with afghanistan and what is biden
done okay first off here's the beauty of
this you can read trump's withdrawal
deal
yeah it's not that hard to find it's
available on the state department
website at state.gov and of course for
people who are watching we always
provide all of our references you go to
lotteries crowder.com i think we have
the link in description of every video
there's usually like 40 to 60 any given
day it's all publicly available just to
make why because we want to do the job
that poppy harlow won't no she won't do
it and i mean poppy female not if i
puppy
and not afghanistan reporter opium poppy
right that's true as well so uh the
timeline from donald trump was set over
nine point nine and a half months yeah
uh withdrawal to be completed as opposed
to joe biden who suddenly was really
over uh
a couple of weeks and here's one thing
too before i get into the technicalities
if people out if there is anyone out
there who does not understand the
difference between okay uh protecting
all of our citizens ambassadors allies
getting getting them out first then our
troops who've protected our citizens and
allies leave and destroy level all of
our [ __ ] our military equipment before
we leave versus withdrawing our military
to leave people to fend for themselves
if you don't understand that difference
you're an idiot or you're being
disingenuous for crying out loud just
play a call of duty game or watch any
action film the last guy to get on the
chopper is the guy with the gun who sits
on the edge you do not withdraw military
before other people especially when you
know that they're going to be overrun by
the taliban anyone who says they don't
understand that fundamental difference
is not being honest and i'll go through
some other differences that's the only
one that matters and we knew about that
obviously not from just experience but
the the people that were leading said
look if you if you guys pull out we will
not be able to hold kabul you'll just
have the airport and they said that's
fine we just need the airport that's it
that's what first off joe biden said uh
there there won't be any complications
right right then he's like well we
couldn't invent it without complications
no americans will be left behind maybe
10 of americans will be left behind you
think i thought do you think he's
ordering milk like uh two and a half
three percent one percent he has no idea
what's going on by the way you don't
water if you don't water a ficus with
milk that ground will be sour
[Laughter]
how do you say that there's gonna be no
complications when there's the talent
it's pretty clear yeah like it's like
well other than the taliban there's
pretty much no i mean the expected some
say they're kind of a wild card yes you
never know what they're gonna do
so uh he does mention they go oh donald
trump released 5000 prisoners by the way
that's true it's called a prisoner
exchange it happens all the time donald
trump released 5000 prisoners in
exchange for a thousand prisoners this
is something that people know as well as
a provision for historic peace deal
something important that people need to
know about donald trump the second the
taliban attacked one american i believe
they killed one american deal was off
the table there were no talks for two
weeks remember when donald trump went to
north korea he crossed over that
national border line people freaked out
he went over and spoke with kim jong-un
said a bunch of nice things right then
the second he understood that kim
jong-un had no interest in
denuclearizing he just left and took a
big [ __ ] on him all over twitter that
was it it was over donald trump's policy
has always been to buy peace we know
that you may not agree with that it's
been to attempt to purchase peace while
holding a big stick in the other hand
yeah so this was a prisoner exchange
that's been going on forever do you know
how i know obama did it many times do
you guys remember the uh when he
released three high-ranking officials
for american trader bro bergdahl who by
the way i don't know if actual death for
treason is a thing but that guy would
fit the criteria for sure um and that
prisoner swept he released the now
commander of the taliban i want to make
sure i get this name right kairullah
kawawaku
perfect
also also making an appearance on sesame
street
this is something too idiots look it was
a prisoner exchange and that was
basically free leverage because think
about this for a second if we're
withdrawing
those prisoners are going to be freed by
the taliban anyway so it's saying let's
get at least a thousand of our prisoners
out at this point because it's going to
be free you see what happens now it's
all you can stop the taliban yeah
exactly at the end of a war in any
situation you always let prisoners go in
exchange for your people back that's
right that's how you do this donald
trump was methodically walking towards a
much more planned exit strategy but you
don't release three top ranking
officials for bo bergdahl you're like oh
you got who do you have we have beau
bergdahl well that's four thousand
mouths we don't have to feed
four thousand you know we save a lot of
it
if bows on the other side of the table
and you want your leadership back i'm
like i think you should keep him for a
while maybe he he needs to be over there
for a little bit look i've been very
open on the show about my political
leanings and as the resident moderate in
this studio i wanted to bring on a
liberal guest to kind of explain why he
thinks biden's you know true yeah that's
the right one so maybe we can get
another perspective it's all right um do
we have uh we haven't it looks like we
got him in here
who is this dave hello guys uh i i
forget what is your what is your name oh
uh
my name is uh jeff
hmm right from portland from cage
that's your last name jeff my friends
call me oh okay okay well thanks for
calling in man yeah yeah thank you good
to talk to you now why do you think that
what biden did was the right strategy uh
well biden's strategy was it was much
simpler see with with trump's it was
very over complicated there was a lot of
as as most things trump does over
complicated and underdeveloped there was
a lot of is that a rocket launcher
this is a uh t-shirt uh shooter
it shoots flannel coexist t-shirts oh oh
i was just working at this relatively
that seems benign that seems it doesn't
look like that though
you know i'll take his word for it well
i think he may have just put a co-exist
sticker on a very dangerous weapon how
do you feel about weapons
weapons are the the weapons we we've had
recently have been wonderful i mean
we're distributing them all all over in
portland so you're you're oh
for for portland uh
no weapons here in portland well you
just said you had them and were
distributing them and it's all you enjoy
you you like weapons as a liberal
uh
well if weapons
are used you know educationally if
crimes are committed with weapons and
then the next generation can see how
okay let me i don't i want to jump in
earlier
did trump did president trump plan on
removing uh the military before
civilians that's something we want to
know yeah there you go yeah he made me i
have that like i was saying the plan was
very sloppy there was there was a lot of
well
if our troops are here then the taliban
has to be over there and then when we
move the troops that the taliban can
move again it's very very sloppy well
that he plan on abandoning our secure
air base bagram air base in the middle
of the night without even telling our
allies that seems kind of pivotal yeah i
haven't read i haven't read all of it do
you mean sloppy like dangerous or like a
poet who lives uh with her cats
um the the uh dangerous dangerous yeah
okay
um now it is it has been well known i
don't know why you're asking someone
from portland but uh it's well known
that uh that uh former vice president
joe biden
actually gave a name
what was that it was was that the death
to america
oh it was uh part of the music festival
i'm i'm currently yeah i'm at a at a new
music co-exist music festival but i
thought they weren't isn't that a super
spreader yeah
well
we believe raising awareness uh is
another way to combat the virus okay uh
let me ask you this final question
because donald
trump did donald trump this is one thing
that really bothers me that you have joe
biden again if people out there don't
understand the difference between
don't understand the difference between
uh leveling all of our crap and actually
handing over a list and biometric
scanners of americans left and our
afghan allies uh that's what joe biden
did do you know did donald trump plan on
giving the taliban the identity in
biometric scanners of our allies when we
left oh i i'm not i'm not sure
that actually happened
that sounds like conspiracy
uh internet conspiracies what's your
take on a woman behind the wheel of a
car
oh oh that is uh very dangerous in uh
usually haram all right okay
nope come on
that was really um i'm sorry that went
off the rails i feel like a little bit
no listen it was fruity you lied in his
email i uh
need better vetting than e-mail
oh better security than you also said
money yeah i did
but i'm supposed to get a lot more back
i don't understand people think can
someone look you can cut again the best
thing you can do is comment i want
someone to play devil's advocate on this
what possible reason could there be
to give over the identities names and
biometric scanners of our allies to the
taliban oh it's taliban uber
they said they were just i guess uh and
i'm getting a little out of breath so
what is that
oh it's just good so i can get a break
it's weird it's a chinese fire truck
okay
okay all right
oh we did it
hey nice job huh hey wang bring him his
water i see chair
no chair not for you not for you not for
you oh well
oh i need to get that water you i don't
want you to get hurt no thank you one
don't drink the covered water you're
getting up again i gotta run it
ah it's fine there's a good chunk of uh
what it's a good chunk of uh spittle no
just the missing piece of well that was
me i went and shipped all the available
mugs just for funsies well sure by the
way for people watching we didn't know
if i was gonna be able to host this show
right today because i still have some
diminished lung capacity so severely
diminished lung capacity again my own
doing uh so now i can take a little bit
of a break p here in third chair while
dave can take over the reins but this
way we still get to do shows so we'll
see depending on the day you may see me
in this chair more uh more or less yeah
where's your mask
uh i don't know but i'm gonna lick this
microphone i'm a nurse and you're
running properly i'll do that
[Laughter]
he was the more spit the better
i uh well let's talk about this ahoy
everybody hello hey hello we've got a
lot of people in studio today
start from zero just start from the very
beginning and of course uh our favorite
is back the reason why you even watched
this show stephen crowder yeah yeah we
love having you glad to be here yeah uh
so we have the segment now we have the
segment on ivormectin and yes we do
thank you
uh well joe rogan as you know recently
set the world to blaze by talking about
ivermectin uh after he was diagnosed
with covid i got up in the morning got
tested
and turns out i got covered so we
immediately threw the kitchen sink out
all kinds of meds monoclonal antibodies
uh ivermectin
zpac
uh
prednisone
everything
do you have prompter dave i do on camera
yep i do oh okay oh because i'm looking
down yeah i didn't know because i
don't use prompter so i normally use
prompter and then i i'm trying to
pretend like i'm not yeah
but you pointed it out i know no i did i
screwed him i totally screwed dave i'm
sorry look i understand you're totally
believable before i was trying to help
you because i'm just trying to hope
not used to being in third chair guys
it's a different he likes third chair he
tells me i do it's fun he texts me too
like being at someone else's party like
your job is easy
remember that when you cast your check
joe rogan freaked people out well he did
and now the media wants you to believe
that ever mectin is just veterinary
medicine intended for livestock right
on top of everything else the fda has to
warn people not to take livestock
dewormer doctors say oklahomans are
using the kaldi warming medicine
ivermectin to treat or prevent cova 19.
for those who may not know the main
ingredient of horse warmer
is ivermectin ivermectin has gotten a
lot of attention lately as people try to
push some other means of covert
protection and treatment okay other than
just getting the covert vaccine okay
pause real quick we have more but right
i think but that's one this is something
that really bothers me okay
as an alternative treatment oh an
alternative to what when people are
talking again we're not giving any
medical advice when people say as an
alternative treatment what treatment do
they give you right now for coverage i'm
not talking about a vaccine yeah which
people obviously should should make that
decision between them and their
prescribing physician of course everyone
should have the right and decision to uh
control their own body and what they put
in their own body
what treatment though if you already
have covet if you go to the hospital now
they say go home and take tylenol come
back in and they toss you on a
ventilator in other words let's say
ivermectin were used which it has been
in some other countries we cannot argue
whether it's been used effectively or
not because that's not a lot on youtube
however i think we could say joe rogan
did effectively use it though or at
least in his opinion along with the
monoclonal yeah
and the vital antibodies
yeah but three days later he tested
negative but the point is i say as an
alternative treatment let's say you used
ivermectin let's say you use
hydroxychloroquine let's say you used
whatever it could be vitamin c cashton
garud take your pick
it would be in lieu of what treatment
given to you at the hospital
none they don't give you money right now
they say tylenol come back and they toss
you on a ventilator there are no
treatments if you get the flu right
let's say you get a flu shot you can
still get the flu you go in they have
treatments that they give you for the
flu that is not the case with covid
that's my point there when they say oh
as an alternative treatment
first off alternative approved by the
fda prescribed to hundreds of millions
of people but alternative to what covet
treatment at that point well i think if
you're elderly they try to put you in
with other elderly people where somebody
can hit you yes oh and then they fill
those homes with elderly crips yes it's
called punch the covet out of your face
i agree with you but i have heard that
horses love it
i yeah that's that's
yeah
that's weird that's a problem he's
having a good time that's how you
actually have more of that clip oh yes
oh the montage
was complaining
so things are clearly bad but they're
being made even worse by people who have
refused to take the vaccine and instead
are swallowing horse pace what would you
tell someone uh who is considering
taking that drug oh god
don't do it there's no evidence
whatsoever that that works and it could
potentially
have toxicity as you've just mentioned
with people who have gone to poison
control centers because they've taken
the drug at a ridiculous dose and wind
up getting sick there's no clinical
evidence
that indicates that this works oh so
taking mega doses is a problem just like
tylenol or aspirin huh for liver
patients yeah
makes perfect sense anyone who calls it
horse dewormer any reporter is guilty of
journalistic male practice oh yeah well
that's what i love is the people online
who are just like horse dewormer haha
and then they snort ketamine yes yeah
right like all right well let's admit
it's not just for animals right and tail
shampoo and i'm like yeah we're crying
out loud danny bonaduce was on uh
steroids that were supposed to be used
for bulls he's on that but it worked for
him yeah he really hey turned into a
bull look at that guy did you guys ever
see that one where he threw that gay
reality star over his shoulder yeah have
you guys seen that video no all right
someone bring it over
we'll bring it up on uh on mug club but
yeah he comes on stage and there's a gay
there's a gig
from a reality show i don't remember the
gay guy wasn't he he goes out to hug
danny bonaduce and he jumps on him wraps
his legs around him as a woman would and
goes like ah like gyrates and danny
from survivor is that it must be johnny
is danny wearing uh bedazzled jeans
because he's pretty good at that yeah he
is and he throws him and you hear the
guy's teeth hit the stage
well bring it on mud club it is
hysterical but sorry continue he
single-handedly made ed hardy a very
rich
uh well ivermectin is for humans it is
an anti-parasitic medicine uh with an
over 30 year history in treating humans
the nobel prize in physiology of
medicine was awarded to and i want to
make sure i'm saying this right satyoshi
amura and william campbell who
discovered it in 1975. what's a fun way
of saying the white guy took it
[Laughter]
we'll both say
thank you satoshi's let me hang on to it
for a second yeah yeah oh you discovered
this me too
i'm the thomas edison of the medicine
world satoshi's at his loft he just sees
it above the toilet he's like is that uh
no no no no no no no no no no it's a
replica yeah yeah i took yours and i
made it better i added sugar
and it's so effective uh and with such
an incredible safety pro uh safety
profile that it it has been on the who's
list of essential medicines for almost
20 years yeah that is that is the
world's health organization world health
organization
not the band right yes the guy who
researches child porn for an acting role
right yes um
which was also really awkward when
daniel day lewis did it yes well he was
like leave me my child born that's not
that's yeah that's not method acting man
in the movie my left hand
oh
oh come on that was come on brilliant no
this is again something that has a long
history
being used with human beings and it's
just amazing when
i don't think oh okay i feel like i say
this a lot but it's definitely one of
the most clear displays of blatant media
bias trying to miss your story yeah well
but it means another story that we had
you remember when hydroxychloroquine was
being promoted uh by a ton of people you
mean french cleaner exactly we had the
fish tank cleaner thing like listen
don't go take fish cleaner then some
broad officer husband like here take
this this is gonna cure you yeah
he happened to die
who knew it's a terrible thing but what
a great story that she was like no i
just i just heard this on the news
here's your here's your medicine here's
some swiss miss
she just did it while he was holding his
head under water in a pool
she taps it on the top right okay
well it's the same as injecting bleach
no one said that no one
said that at all and by the way they're
let's say that it it
it's used in veterinary medicine there
are tons of drugs that are using
veterinary medicine for example uh when
i had ketamine yeah ketamine they used
ketamine to put me out uh for my surgery
oh you got a little k-hole surgery well
noah what they gave me i guess it's the
right dosage because it just puts you
out and i came back a total completely
clear i was surprised because i remember
any of it
from my friend paul
paul mayo
there you go oh something something dose
of ketamine and i go what the [ __ ]
you're like you're giving me horse
tranquilizer like yeah but we use it
here too so ketamine got a hemp necklace
pepcid prilosec benadryl gabapentin
something we had to use with our dogs uh
anti-anxiety medication xanax xanax yeah
there are all kinds of medications that
are used in humans and animals
and if you look at ivermectin it has
been prescribed to how many how many
people uh have been prescribed uh i've
remembered i think millions millions
have been prescribed for infections
there's all kinds of infections you can
get uh well there's what there's uh
river blindness uh which is aka eyeball
worms thread worms which is aka
elephantitis
scabies uh the one that your dad warned
you about those girls with the scabies
who is diagnosing all of the is it davey
jones the pirate
he's like you probably got eyeball worms
from the river blindness here's a lemon
higher boy throw in my room be sure not
to open me scabies
probably got thread worm there's no
doubt about it look at those giant balls
he's got hook hands it's even been used
for rosacea for uh celtic
yeah i got a little uh celtic in me do
you yeah do you get roses and by the way
some people are saying oh it's
anti-parasitic it's not well there are
plenty of anti-parasitic medications
that have antiviral properties and i
don't have time to get into the
difference between antiseptic
antibacterial antiviral anti-parasitic
but there is absolute crossover
depending on how it affects the cell
membrane the lipid layer so it's not
unheard of at all for medications to be
used off label and this has been over
250 million people i think is a number
and oh yeah that is right that's the
actual number 250 million a quarter
billion if you will annually wow
a year
they've served as many people ever
mektin as mcdonald's has burgers
they have to they have to it's a
rounding error if titty tattoo is well
that's true i mean it depends on the
person
watch her go to the drive-through and
look at the numbers change oh yes do you
think that she had to hold it up for him
to tattoo yes yeah 100 there's a she has
a mechanism going on she had to flip it
up like the original starbucks mermaid
logo or maybe he had like assistance
yeah
no you would have to have a system you
have to tie that right yeah
did you know that the original starbucks
logo is a is a siren and you actually
see the full boobs yeah really yeah yeah
yeah if you zoom out yeah we'll talk
about that on mug club that's true yeah
that's true you see full boobs and it's
like her spreading her boobs i've never
wanted to see that list is it an
original one or i know she's a mermaid
but is it a specific is it in every
single starbucks
originally they kind of cut it was the
mermaid siren yeah where you saw the
boobs mermaid mermaids wore manatees
correct and they thought they were
that's how the yeah is that true i have
no idea because it wasn't yeah they were
it was from drinking salt water and they
saw the they were submitting these and
they thought they were halfway
i tried that sex one of them
i had the hottest half fish lady at sea
you'd never guess oh man davey jones
that was a that was a manatee i thought
it was i thought it'd be a tick tucker
she lured me in i couldn't tell i can't
see from the eye worms
[ __ ] how gross
that's a real thing i need something
parasitic or is it antiviral i don't
know this has taken place centuries
before term theory let's be a ventilator
we have better medicine back then
by the way we're not making any any
medical claims no we have clearly not
doctors merely made an observation that
various countries
are researching ivermectin as a
treatment and prevention against covid
that's it yeah research and i know and i
can hear some people now and gerald
because your wife is a nurse yeah you
know like people make it something well
actually the maker of ivermectin is it
merck merck mark
yeah they said it doesn't it doesn't
work for covet uh well here's the thing
sure they're the maker their patent
expired in 1996 so you can get a two
dollar generic pill and they were just
granted 350 something million dollars to
create their own covid vaccine again all
references available at the website
link in the description 300 you know
what hey uh drugs how much money can you
make off merc uh merc how much money can
you make off of ivermectin no
350 million dollars for a vaccine and
then a multi-billion dollar government
contract makes a little more sense than
something less profitable than aspirin
well i love how all of a sudden the
clinical trials and you know data over
you know several years matters yeah all
of a sudden all of a sudden that's a
very important thing and by the way in
that merc release they actually said at
the current dosages that we were
studying and with the the population so
they had some qualifiers there so that
they could cover themselves just a
little bit right it was so easy to find
too that's what bothers me the most
where you can just see oh this isn't
profitable yeah right it was that oh
well because that's the attack that the
left has always used if you were saying
you know for example there is no no
before they became the voice of big
pharma before they came to the voice of
big pharma there can be no vested
interest in something like ivermectin
and something like hydroxychloroquine we
know that they're obviously i mean what
a brilliant business model right now
we're talking about the vaccine and i'm
not even i'm not even attributing any
nefarious motivation at all you want to
take the trump vaccine you can thank
donald trump for it you can take the
trump vaccine but what a brilliant
business model to create a vaccine and
then god knows what's going to happen
with the variant because there are
variants with all kinds of coronaviruses
that have existed through that since the
beginning since the inception of
coronaviruses and now because of a
variant you need another booster and of
course there will be another variant and
you're going to need another booster you
basically just so once you join that
circus you better stick along for the
ride for the rest of your life because
they didn't tell you that and there are
a lot of people right now look you want
to solve vaccine hesitancy then you need
to be straightforward about it and tell
people we are just going to demand
never-ending boosters as soon as there's
a variant that comes out and we know
that coronaviruses mutate and it's very
likely you'll be having to do them
you know not even like a flu shot every
year right now what are they talking
about after four months
twice a year perhaps they could say it's
a rushed vaccine maybe maybe i'm not
trying to say it some people maybe it
doesn't well but in in in you know
ireland sorry in israel right now
totally different countries by the way
yeah different very different people one
of them drinks heavy yeah they were i'll
leave that to you to find out they were
i did
they were saying that you know you have
to have two vaccine shots to be able to
go out and have a vaccine passport and
do stuff and now they're saying if you
don't have the third you're treated as
essentially unvaccinated like if you
don't have the booster you are now back
to being unvaccinated and so the goal
post just keeps moving in these things
so don't don't think we're like
conspiracy theorists we're like this is
happening real time in other countries
yeah well what bothers me is at least as
per the cdc it's actually being given to
refugees from um all uh like middle
eastern ivermectin yeah yeah i've ever
met him yeah
has been given to
all refugees i believe from the middle
east asian north africa north africa
latin america caribbean countries not
for covid so
just in case the overlords at big tech
we're not saying that they're giving it
to them for cover we're saying that
they're giving it to them for parasites
that are often brought in and we're not
saying that refugees are parasites we're
not even saying that they're paris
they're not we're not even saying that
they are parasite riddled we are just
saying that the cdc
recommends
all of these uh mass hysteria refugees
uh by the way given ivermectin lilly
just sent in that uh merkin's launching
new trials of oral covet 19 drugs oh
look at that it's going to be
hypermechanical
oh look it turns out we had the care
laying around who knew
we were filing patent paper i mean
trials i was using it to level my desk
because i ran out of sugar packets
that rogan guy's talking about it we
better get on this oh my gosh she has so
much influence how do you make 240
million on spotify i can't i can't
we can't compete
i feel like joe just took everything
that would piss off the media he's like
i don't even i don't even know if he
really had cove but i think he did but
can you imagine like the just oh he
looks like
he was like let's do this i'm gonna take
everything that they're hating in three
days is gonna be gone he was like a
squid of middle fingers yeah oh yeah
everywhere everything and then he tested
negative three days later that's what i
love
it's the same as the media how we're not
saying again take it we're just saying
that calling it horse dewormer is not
true but
about joe is yeah he took it everybody
you know all of a sudden you get half of
the country not half the country but a
good portion of people basically wishing
death on him because they're so
progressive
and then he beats it in three days i
realize when you said joe is thinking
former vice president joe biden because
i always hear joe rogan no like joe took
ivermec and then now i understand i
don't think he's going to beat what he
has
no
that's terminal
someone stabbing him with a dopamine pen
like uh like uh russell crowe and 310 to
you they're gonna hang me in the morning
oh my gosh like hillary maybe don't do
that i forgot how much my chest hurts
dude in the 90s axel rose came out more
promptly than the president
it doesn't make any sense
and here's something too when people say
you know in their last breath i blame
the unvaccinated oh jeez i don't want it
i blame the fat
right this is another well you know
unless it's on a steak because sometimes
that is yeah i do love a ribeye anyone
who picks a new york strip over a rib
eye needs to be honest don't get it
like it's right there but this brings us
when we're talking about covid
that
we only talk about the health care
system yeah what what happened to
wellness but i think we're allowed to
talk about that
on youtube and on big tech about
actually being healthy about actually
keeping yourself well uh before you
really get any kind of transmissible
virus or or disease yeah and and i think
this brings us to another um well i
actually did i did see a bit of that
though after he recovered that you saw
from the left going well yeah look at
how much he works out look at how he
takes care of himself of course he beat
in three days and it's like okay so what
is it why is everything an argument if
you really care about human life let's
look at how this works right and instead
they're just trying to create more mass
hysteria about the delta variant yeah
let's go
and the cdc director is calling the
delta cova variant one of the most
infectious respiratory viruses she's
ever seen the state is also seeing an
alarming spike in cases among children
but with that delta variant quickly
spreading across the country health
officials are concerned at least some of
these bikers may take home more than
just a few memories
let me tell you
uh judy it's a significant threat well
robin this is not your grandfather's
kovitz
oh they should have never they should
have never hired the slogan writer for
jaws
[Laughter]
now your grandpappies yeah well my
grandfather's dead so
know it i'll be back
just when you thought it was safe to go
back to the icu now you're dead just
when you thought it was safe to take off
your mask
you're dead covered this time it's
deltanola
yeah delta force wasn't no delta force
two yeah with those fours too i mean
delta force was also but in a fun way
yeah yeah i like chuck norris yeah to be
honest so
i think that this is something too we
need to talk about what you'll talk
about texas ranger architect actually no
i have a story about that we'll tell it
later um there are over 300 how many
people in america 300 million in america
and over 40 million cases
of kovitz yeah so about 40 million cases
of covet 300 million americans and then
in two so in two years yes keep in mind
too a flu season is measured from a uh
gerald your your wife's
a nurse is it measured from uh is it
september through april or is it october
may i think it's something right around
that yeah so it's like fall to spring
right so that's when they measure flu
season but we're talking about now two
years basically 13 of the population
that it's affected there have been six
hun uh how many deaths dave you have the
numbers uh i believe it's
666. that oh no 666.
666. oh that means only one thing
[Music]
[Music]
nice mask
[Music]
say what you want about devil walrus he
is multifaceted when it comes to
employment he really is and you know he
he might terrorize you but he still
cares about the health of others yeah
he's still working working to take care
of you he's not sitting on unemployment
right now he might kill you but he's
going to make sure you don't get sick i
don't know how much that mask works
yeah it's up here
so that means when you do the numbers is
it zero point two zero point no point
two percent of the population yeah zero
point two percent
now here's i think i think what matters
though too is we can i think we need to
look at that so 0.2 percent of the
population have died from covet this is
assuming by the way no false positives
this is assuming that no one died with
covet as opposed to from kovid like
someone who i don't know died from a
motorcycle accident or tried to blow
their head off with a shotgun and was
listed as a cove of death let's just
assume all these numbers are accurate
that's a conversation we've had in other
shows we'll have links in the
descriptions um i think then it does
matter 0.2 percent if there's a
disproportionate uh
i guess i should say enclave of society
who was affected by covid who are those
people those numbers matter and i
believe dave has them
well uh
well now i'm just seeing where well the
numbers are fairly small right i mean
yeah now what age group
is the most affected by cofid uh well we
know it's over 85 years old okay so 85
years old had the highest coveted death
rate of uh
1797 per 100 000 in the u.s which
that's not i mean that's not horribly
i mean it's horrible if somebody dies
but if you're 85 i think one of the
things that might kill you is just uh
you you're being 85. you know time
you're up there it's fine if i hit 85
i'm gonna be very surprised getting your
balls trapped under your hover round oh
can you imagine getting oh tangled with
other guys but i was going to the grand
canyon
not today
i hurt all the time
are you my wife
[Laughter]
no oh thank god
that's what i hated about the notebook
would you really just rush to the
hospital to remind your wife who you are
i'd be like is she still not knowing
stuff
all right i'm all right i'll be back in
two months hopefully it'll be a burial
tell her to
tell her she's miss oklahoma what the
hell is it yeah
i'm gonna make up a new story every day
until she freaks out on me yeah by the
way
and this is the thing too
when you say is it a tragedy it does
matter because studies from i think it
was yesterday in italy right they found
that the average uh death age i don't
know if it was the average the median
the mean was 80 years old by comparison
life i mean life expectancy is 78 yeah
and italy has i believe uh a
proportionately larger number of old
elders
yeah so very much so i mean that's going
to be exactly what should happen that's
kind of what you would expect and this
is nation is necessary when trying to
diagnose how you're going to treat
people around the world and what kind of
measures you need to put in place to
save them not throwing old folks back in
with other old folks when they're sick
would probably be a place to start cuomo
[Music]
yeah that's true
whitmer just saying to me
i'm just saying nothing whitmer would do
that i think she's a stand-up gal yes
yes
i'd like to take her to a dance she
stands up on stilts with striped
stockings she's a bad woman they just
roll up under that house every time
she's next to the cauldron with bette
midler
she's the only governor who has on hand
for some reason in her carry-all eye of
newt
you never know
you just never know oh she's the worst i
mean she's great yeah
so good maybe you should call feds and
have you kidnapped uh so let's be clear
this dance from them
oh what's so funny is you can say that
because it's been proven yeah uh now
let's be clear the stance from the media
has been the only facet to address covid
uh is vaccines were nothing yeah
vaccines are nothing and some doctors
they're even refusing to to treat
patients uh who haven't been vaccinated
which is crazy i just can't imagine
you know what okay what if a doctor said
oh well your bmi is uh bacon grease so
i'm not serving you right i'm not
helping you this was entirely
preventable i have been your uh primary
physician for 10 years you've never lost
weight as a matter of fact you've gained
weight because you became a a member of
the fat pride movement and uh i'm
through with it i'm tired of i'm tired
of pushing the boulder uphill yeah
they'd cut up your license right well
rightfully so right they're like oh you
smoke yes sorry i it's tough that you
can't breathe right now but we need the
oxygen for other people who are making
better life choices right right well
it's like candace owns you just wanted
to get a yeah a test to make sure she
didn't well that was because she was
black uh yeah that's true they refused
it he googled her he didn't read
anything about her he just saw her face
and was like nah nah
you go somewhere else not in these parts
i don't test that i don't cut the hair
so i
[Laughter]
go me some coconut oil call it a day
yeah she was trying to do the right
thing and then you have somebody who
disagrees with you like could you
imagine having to agree with every
doctor you've ever met on every
political stance oh my god in order to
get help it's like well he bled out
we didn't even finish the conversation
how many people die because of stupid
decisions like have you seen the the
show's faces of death and stuff like
that or get hurt or maimed that's pretty
much you gotta fill out a questionnaire
when you go in well how did you do that
to yourself well yeah whatever lie
you're gonna write down yeah exactly
you're like oh you mean how how did the
cucumber get in my ass oh well
i i slept in a grocery store i'm a real
butterfly
uh you know i was feeling
self-self-punitive they're talking to
her husband he's like i was just trying
to uh be with the sexier one
i was trying to end it look at my wife
you see here we know that it affects the
old we've known that if yes
so let's very small percentage when
we're looking at the numbers of young
people get covered but i think it
matters what could be a factor in young
people dying oh yeah
number one risk factor obesity oh
obesity nobody could have seen anyone
under the age of 65. was it the end was
it uh the nih fund do you think you have
that in front of that the nh-funded
study uh found obese patients under 65
for at a significantly higher risk of
death or
uh your overall from covet and not
patients over 16. but i think there's a
number wasn't it like three times or
something more likely um yeah three
times three times a higher risk of
hospitalization one point
one and a half times
higher risk of severe illness accord by
the way according to the cdc yeah this
is all them 65 is young yeah well anyone
under the age of 65 because that's a cut
off where something happens with your
immune system the same reason that
vaccines don't necessarily interact the
same with old people young people oh if
you're following the science it would be
interesting to know how immune systems
change mature how they weaken also why
people who have blood type pudding are
at greater risk so i think that's sort
of a self-explanatory issue according to
the cdc a three-time somebody else
snapped in the playground
a three-time high risk of
hospitalization but you can't say it
because we've said that everything is
that all every every body type is
healthy yeah and so when you see have
you guys seen these stories there's like
says young healthy teen dies
oh no oh i know and it's i was actually
very rude on one of them do we have
pictures of the people from those do we
have some don't but i can pull some
let's pull some up let's pull something
that's not what you think well one of
them is like this guy pulls up in a van
he's like you want some candy he's like
no i got diabetes
that's what i that's what i like to hear
oh these kids are easy to catch now you
just need a net
they can't run his face they all got the
sugar pictures
sugar foot's my favorite term i know
it's great it's the best
well when you see stories
okay i got a picture oh yeah here we go
this is the young article all right now
young health we're all at home let's be
careful we're not making fun of any of
these people no not at all we're trying
to showing you well
especially if you're a young and a kid
at this age we're not making fun of it
all we're just trying to say like i i'm
a father your father your father yeah
look at look you have to look you're a
father you have to look after your
children
it's not the kid's fault it's the
parents it is the person yeah well there
was a picture of somebody in ohio and it
said young healthy person i think this
was like a cnn article and she was she
was very much overweight and i said like
that it was very sad but that you had to
weigh all of the factors when somebody
dies i didn't mean that to be a pun i
wasn't trying to be a jerk and so i got
all these responses that were like wow
that's a brilliant joke
this must this must affect you a ton is
this really weighing on your i'm like
all these like drive like what did i say
i went back and i was like oh oh no by
the way we have all those links
available at the website there's one
from the sun cnn abc yahoo news 3
memphis there's like there's so many
examples of perfectly healthy but you
can't say that's unhealthy when you've
been mounting a pr campaign to tell
everyone that uh that they have to
recognize
i should just wrote we really gotta chew
the fat before we determine oh dude
anyways
well stephen don't you i'm not that
sorry you make a better point i'm just
laughing at a fat joke there's been
there's been this whole national
movement stephen to make sure people get
in shape and lose weight so that they
have a better chance of surviving covet
if they were to get it right we've seen
that all over the country right it's all
over all over the world in fact yeah
they demand that you recognize them as
healthy even if they are morbidly obese
i think we have a montage this is the
west memphis uh oh west family oh west
memphis family
for crying
did i do
you did mess up the prompter there just
hit the little check mark it just
slipped
hit the check we're in the top left dave
for crying out loud he's he treats
computers like he's the average coach
let me get my glasses i nobody said i
knew how to use computers uh no there's
so they've been demanding that you
recognize them this is where we are
people who are morbidly obese as
beautiful fit and brave here you go this
is what creates a pandemic
get medical equipment that will actually
work for fat patients like blood
pressure cups that fit and won't give a
false high reading because they're too
tight set up their office in a way that
makes it usable for fat people like
putting chairs without arms in every
room when you go to a clothing store
tell them to expand their size range it
does not matter what their size range
currently is tell them to expand it
people keep asking me to clarify what a
b belly is i did shoot a video
explaining this a couple months ago but
now it's so far down on the list that
people can't find it so
it looks like the capital letter b
that's the long and short of it so this
is what mine looks like there's a chubby
upper part
that looks like the top of the letter b
and a chubby lower part that looks like
the bottom part and then there is a
waistband
in the middle separating the two where
your belly button is now this
this is a bikini body
well sure if you're just slapping things
that aren't things you're saying they
are bikini body
acid in my throat that's that that
second to last uh that second to last uh
don't
be nice i thought like oh okay she's
she's cute and then she's like
yeah and then she like zoomed out i
think they're going for buoyancy i think
it's just a nice fupa
look there's curves there and then
there's and then there's when you when
you create new appendages
yeah that don't have a problem yeah look
i mean this is the thing when people say
oh look anyone who's on vaccine you have
blood on your hands okay well anyone who
isn't speaking out against the obesity
you have lard on your hands that's true
or pudding very slippery and eventually
your hands are good
crisco yes either way
like a seagull in a bp oil spill your
hands yes oh yes oh
yes gerald
have you been to a vp oil spill i heard
it's not a good time no it's well it
depends if you hate seagulls it's pretty
fun
i uh that's why i throw six pack holders
in the seat
they don't even make them anymore
and i just keep them to litter let's go
down to the gulf with a giant can of pam
[Laughter]
just looking for bottlenecks just
grabbing a bird and putting gasoline on
it you got
are you going to burn that no no he's
just what he wants to live with
it's a pterodactyl bird from the sims
from the flintstones who can talk
now this is sit go
what we're saying is you can blame the
unvaccinated all you want but you are at
a far greater risk and a far greater
burden
on our health care system if you choose
to remain
at an entirely preventable and
reversible metaboli metabolic state
of obesity it's something you can change
it's something you can control it's
something that will affect your
capability to fight off viruses diseases
of any kind as you move forward is diet
and exercise and it certainly is more
relevant as we're trying to create the
social safety net of socialized
healthcare and i come from canada where
i experienced it and it sucks i'll do it
when we're talking about offloading the
costs onto other people we have an
obesity problem in this country i don't
think that people who are obese should
should be uh uh ashamed and and secluded
from society but i certainly don't think
that we should be lying to people
telling them that it's all healthy all
body types are healthy and then blaming
a pandemic on the unvaccinated when the
fact is the obese in this country are
the most hardest hit and you can even
look at a geographical map it reads it
reads basically like a franchise
pamphlet for jack in the box so people
out there you can uh you can comment uh
of course youtube uh thank you so much
uh everyone who's been watching first
show back yeah the show every
monday through thursday 10 a.m eastern
you can tune in we're going to be here
tomorrow we're going to go talk about
lizzo
we are and uh again i'll be in spokane
this weekend but until then
you want to say it yeah i feel like it
should be you man okay youtube
you can piss off
you